sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola bienvenidos a corresponsales de
france 24 soy santiago lópez gonzález
por andrés espinal los analistas
militares aún debaten porque las fuerzas
rusas no lograron apoderarse de kiev la
capital ucraniana al comienzo de la
guerra las respuestas son muchas y son
complejas por supuesto pero una táctica
que ayudó a ucrania fue el autosabotaje
el ejército ucraniano destruyó puentes
también carreteras clave para
obstaculizar el avance ruso en un caso
incluso inundaron una población completa
nuestros reporteros nadie más y bastian
gen hui y riad a woods a 10 viajaron
hasta esta zona para ver como los
residentes están lidiando con la
inundación intencional de sus hogares
una inundación táctica suena
contradictorio pero eso es exactamente
lo que sucedió aquí a 60 kilómetros al
norte de la capital el segundo día de la
guerra el ejército ucraniano amenazado
con abrir la presa de irving para
inundar el campo y detener los tanques
rusos la desventaja el agua lleno del
pueblo de de madrid
el agua llegó a este nivel todo
esto
en comparación con lo que está pasando
en otras partes de ucrania
no estamos sufriendo así que nuestro
de oreo decor iván no es el único que
apoya a las inundaciones pero las
reparaciones llevarán tiempo solo tienen
esta bomba para todo el pueblo
de
h
podemos tiene mal
la presa en sí fue escenario de feroces
combates y ahora está inoperable antes
de la batalla este empleado ayudó a
abrir la cerradura e inundó del pueblo
ya no hay problema
creo que fue una buena idea hacerlo
porque de lo contrario los tanques rusos
habrían podido pasar fácilmente pero en
cambio los tanques se atascaron y kiev
estaba a salvo
no sólo fue la represa el ejército
ucraniano
deliberadamente destruyó al menos 300 de
sus puentes para ralentizar el avance
ruso
al menos la mitad de la provincia de
savory ya está en poder de las fuerzas
rusas un equipo de france 24 ha visitado
la población de origen de 14.000
habitantes que es la última en control
ucraniano en esta región las tropas
rusas están a sólo unos cuantos
kilómetros y lanzan constantemente
ataques contra la población actualmente
solo cuatro mil personas permanecen allí
la mayoría de ellos son adultos mayores
que no tienen los medios económicos para
poder escapar o para refugiarse
esta mañana los ataques de han un
respiro y junto con otros habitantes de
origin lugo espera la llegada de ayuda
humanitaria
yo decidí quedarme y mi esposo también
está en contra de irse sea lo que sea
esté preparado para nosotros no se puede
evitar esta población tenía 14.000
habitantes ha pasado a ser la última
bajo control ucraniano en esta área al
sur de la provincia de sap orilla las
fuerzas rusas están a pocos kilómetros
quienes se quedaron aprovechan las horas
del día para abastecerse de provisiones
porque dicen que necesitamos
libertadores de que debemos ser
liberados
cada uno intenta sobrellevar las
dificultades de la guerra a su manera no
pasan hambre pero muchos productos han
desaparecido y el dinero también los
cajeros no funcionan y los precios han
aumentado al menos un 30 por ciento
están tratando de tomarse el pueblo
nuestros muchachos no los dejarán entrar
por eso el centro de la ciudad y sus
perímetros están siendo atacados
lo próximo
atacaron en un sector conocido como la
fábrica la gente está huyendo detrás de
la estación de tren
este es el área residencial al que se
refiere dos mil a dos personas murieron
en el apartamento de sergei pocas cosas
han quedado intactas
atacaron este lugar y después de eso
todos los habitantes se fueron los
corredores están vacíos pero muchos no
quieren irse ni pueden hacerlo la
mayoría son personas mayores
una cuenta que no tiene a donde llevar a
su madre de 86 años
grupos de voluntarios intentan ayudarlos
una de ellas es valentina que nació en
1941 una semana después de comenzará la
segunda guerra mundial
su madre el abandono muy pequeña esta
guerra la encuentra sola de nuevo todos
los suyos ha muerto
me preguntan valentina petrona vas a
abandonar el lugar y yo digo dónde voy a
ir abandonar el lugar para el sótano
tomaré mi carreta y llevaré mis cosas
la resistencia de origen comienza por
los mayores que tienen que enfrentarse
nuevamente a una guerra
y las bombas de racimo son especialmente
mortíferas cuando se usan contra la
población civil multiplican el número de
víctimas y de heridos con tan solo un
ataque en jarque en el noreste de
ucrania las unidades especializadas en
desactivar explosivos lidian con ellas a
diario nuestras enviadas especiales
leticia álvarez e irene savio han
acompañado a esta unidad de élite en el
frente de batalla en jarquín
es el momento en el que la brigada de
explosivos retira un cohetes smerch en
la localidad de bessudo fca bombardeada
en los últimos días el misil de la era
soviética mantiene solo su carcasa la
munición impactó en el bosque cercano
antes de mover el proyectil tienen que
asegurar y medir cada paso pues podría
tener munición en su interior un mínimo
error sería fatal
arthur jefe del grupo lo sabe bien dos
stands touch pro son esto trino sufre
pero posible sólo trabajan con la luz
del día acuden a las llamadas de los
vecinos y de las autoridades locales
para retirar restos de municiones
peligrosas tam ya estaba escondida en su
casa cuando un estruendo la puso en
alerta
eran las 10 de la mañana no lo vimos lo
escuchamos al principio pensamos que
eran los perros pero luego nos dimos
cuenta de que no cuando vuelan los
misiles los perros empiezan a ladrar
este grupo especial se juega la vida ya
lo ven recogiendo misiles trozos de
misiles bombas minas y también sus
municiones de bombas de racimo que han
caído aquí en jarquín olec tiene sólo 24
años y lleva desde los 20 trabajando en
esto pero con la guerra cada día es
distinto
lo que más nos encontramos son
fragmentos de misiles smerch o
normalmente la parte trasera del misil o
el tubo pero cada vez más encontramos
dentro de estos misiles munición de
racimo varias organizaciones
internacionales han denunciado el uso de
bombas de dispersión en ucrania o le
confirma que ha retirado este tipo de
arma que es especialmente mortífera
contra objetivos civiles por el número
de pequeñas municiones que se esparcen y
están
si encontramos su munición de racimo no
hemos desactivado por el momento minas
antipersona porque están en la línea de
fuego ahora pero sí que hemos
recolectado minas antitanque cuando las
encontramos acordonamos la zona
evacuamos a quienes estén allí
desactivamos la munición y nos
deshacemos de ella
s
estos son los misiles que recolectaron
desde que empezó la guerra probablemente
servirán para futuras investigaciones
entre los restos hay bombas letales
utilizadas contra la población civil en
ucrania
en afganistán de la cerca de cinco mil
fábricas activas en el país 2000 han
cerrado desde la caída del anterior
gobierno y el regreso del grupo talibán
al poder hace 8 meses el sistema
bancario se ha derrumbado el poder
adquisitivo de los afganos de a pie se
ha caído en picada lo que ha deteriorado
una economía que ya estaba en crisis la
situación de incertidumbre ha cobrado
también un alto precio entre los
empresarios del país por ejemplo en
kabul la capital más de la mitad de las
empresas privadas que operaban han
cerrado y miles de personas han perdido
sus empleos el informe es de asa y bala
y de sonia gets als
el floreciente negocio de exportación de
azafrán de farah cerro hace siete meses
abrió en 2019 pero su joven empresa no
pudo sobrevivir a la toma de posesión de
los talibanes ésta era nuestra oficina
comprábamos este azafrán a los
agricultores de herat y lo enviamos a
eeuu las sanciones internacionales
impuestas al país han hecho mella en su
negocio
fedex no hay dhl no hay fedex así que
ahora mismo no podemos enviar nada desde
afganistán al exterior el dinero del
azafrán que vendíamos en eeuu no puede
ser enviado por mi socio afganistán y no
podemos tomar el dinero de los manos
en kabul más de mil negocios privados se
han cerrado desde que los talibanes
tomaron el poder sin embargo unos pocos
han sobrevivido como es el caso de esta
empresa social fabrica toallas
sanitarias reutilizables pero con la
disminución de los precios las empleadas
cobran sólo unos cincuenta y cuatro
euros al mes aproximadamente la mitad de
lo que ganaban antes del pasado agosto
cuando los talibanes tomaron el poder
estuvimos cerrados durante dos meses
luego reabrimos pero importamos nuestra
materia prima de india y las entregas
directas han cesado así que todo pasa
por dubai y luego llega aquí eso
significa que cuesta más y tarda más en
llegar la otra dificultad es que los
precios de todo han aumentado en
afganistán
este restaurante y karaoke en el centro
de la ciudad no ha vuelto a abrir desde
que los fundamentalistas llegaron a la
capital de kenia fueron ya o no antes
los jóvenes venían aquí se reían tenían
noches de karaoke había conciertos era
muy popular pero ahora está cerrado el
emirato islámico lo ha prohibido
nur mohamad el barbero utiliza sus
ahorros para llegar a fin de mes he
perdido el 60% de mi negocio con el
emirato islámico la mayoría de los
hombres no se arreglan la barba algunos
siguen viniendo pero solo para cortarse
el pelo según el banco mundial la
economía afgana seguirá contrayéndose en
el próximo año
gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de corresponsales de france 24 queremos
agradecer a dar a color que en la ciudad
de bogotá por habernos prestado sus
instalaciones para nuestra grabación del
día de hoy ustedes sigan conectados con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom